when you got out of school you went into
advertising right and it is the funniest
thing to be you learned how to tell a
joke by being an advertising you were an
account manager and and that taught you
a sense of hey man if i'm going to tell
somebody something i better do it
quickly and get the thought out yeah
absolutely i think word economy and like
efficiency but i think also
watching david tell i think it's a new
york stand-up thing is uh kind of get to
the point get the joke out you could see
a lot of guys die on stage saturday the
setup is just so long and also do it you
know do it without emotion like let the
material be
uh the hero were you horrible the first
time you get on stage i think i was
pretty you know it's weird because i
think i was
i think i was okay but then friends
would be like wow you were really bad
so i think i was probably pretty bad i'm
thinking about some of your material
it's so good the the wrap on hors
d'oeuvres you know like appetizers yeah
yeah like try to explain that to
somebody from a poor country that can't
eat yeah what an appetizer is and if
they get confused and they're like uh
and you're like no no no that's dessert
that's what we eat after we eat can you
imagine it's so true like you tell a
starving person yeah first we eat and we
don't eat too much because we know more
food is coming absolutely and then after
that dessert comes yeah and then we put
it in a bag
to bring it home but we don't need that
we just give it to the dog oh my god
where do you come up with a thought like
that you know i uh the food thing i
never um i don't know where that came
from it's not like i came from a
culinary family yeah that discussed food
you can't learn to be a comic you either
you either can come up with that kind of
material you can't you're either damaged
or not right no but seriously i mean
that thought on food it's just such a
good one uh and i don't think your
career was typical you learn how to be a
stand-up by working as an account
manager and you know and watching comics
of course but also your first stand-up
performance was at a business seminar
like you didn't go into a club well you
know i no i definitely was um
i i went
and did improv
i always wanted to to be in the
entertainment industry i just didn't
think it was realistic right and so but
i had such a fear of speaking uh in a
business setting that i did this improv
class right and then um and this is way
before ucb this was you know and then
someone dared me to do stand-up and i
wanted to do it but i did kind of this
very kind of we'll construct your
duh it's so silly right so then i had to
kind of unlearn some of that uh here i'm
going to play some of your beds do you
mind if i play some of your stuff it's
like if you're sitting with a musician
and you play some of his songs right uh
here's jim gaffigan on bowling really
there are two types of people that go
bowling there are people that really
really love bowling and then the other
people that are like wouldn't it be
hysterical if we went bowling
it's for most of us bowling is the
activity you do after you've done
everything else
bowling's great you gotta love a sport
you can eat while you play it
never see that in tennis hey before you
serve let me dig into these nachos
it's a different sport there's an
ashtray built into the bowling equipment
when you do a piece of material like
that you've practiced that like a
million times right yeah first time you
have that thought and you go on stage
with it it probably tanks right you've
got to figure out how to do it there's
usually one or two jokes like there's an
observation that like bowling is
that you know it's like there are people
that love bullying than everybody else
right and so then you get that topic and
then you just keep adding on so that do
you ever go on stage and then
and that's all you got you go uh yeah
both there are two types of people
bowling it's a premise it's not even a
joke absolutely and you do that and you
wait to see what comes out of your mouth
yes you're that loose
i mean yeah i mean i haven't always been
that loose but yeah and if you bring up
that premise and you got nothing
yeah the audience sits and stares you
yeah but you know some of it is if
you've been doing it long enough
almost that awkwardness you can turn
into it but by the time it gets polished
and you turn it into a chunk of material
like that
uh does it get boring to do each time
you do it or is there an excitement
hearing a different audience laugh at
that piece of material
there's an excitement but it's some of
it it's never done right so you change
the order so like say i had like 12 or
15 bowling jokes there's probably five
that i took out and then maybe i'd
change the order right or
change or clarify the point of view and
then like i have this inside voice so
maybe if i feel like i'm going on too
long i'll have the inside voice comment
on it but it's some of it it's fun to to
go on stage and see what you're going to
say you love it
it's it's it's heroin